I mean I wouldn't let people I would
remind people that I was you know half a
Robin Hood that Robin Hood stole from
the rich and gave to the poor and I
stole from the rich and I kept it and
you know and they didn't say it about me
which I think is wait wait why were you
Robin Hood well he's having oh I used to
rob banks I thought you knew that oh I
used to Rob bags
I was 26. I used to rob banks yeah wait
literally it's a real thing
I thought you knew that you didn't know
this thank you wait you guys don't hear
this bullshitting yeah no no I was a
very famous
got it got it how do you rob a bank yeah
that's what got complicated okay like
that was really hard for them to know
yeah like that's where things got really
tough and so a deal was made with jail
and the government a deal was made and
she'll quit robbing banks in exchange
for information
well but it was only on myself yes it
was only information on myself though I
know who DB Cooper is and I was I was no
I tried to to barter with them they
weren't interested how did you meet DB
Cooper my sister's Godfather my parents
grew up with him wow he's dead he passed
away but his wife is back in town where
did he go this is all true I thought you
knew these things I'm sorry I thought
this is why you knew I thought you knew
all these things where did DB Cooper go
get annoying this gangster you didn't
know that they call me the American
Gangster
bank robbing is very complicated I mean
if you put a mask and you're going with
a gun like some I did this with a pen I
never even stepped foot in the back took
off millions of dollars these are very
bad people by the way these are terrible
people terrible people yeah they took
like took my grandmother's property and
tried to say that she refinanced and she
owed it and blah blah blah they got her
to sign she was at a diminished capacity
at best she was 86 years old she was a
little Widow they were providing her
company some some guy he brings her
papers because they're a sign they try
to take her Farm away whoa and they said
that they told that to my family when he
said she's 86 years old she never even
took the money wow my grandfather had
the deed on this long before he died
which was before I was even born I said
well she signed for it says oh that's
the game we're playing so then you get a
sign I got pretty good getting them oh I
got it all back she died in that she
died in that farm not only she died in
that farm she had a Cadillac in the
garage that was because of her grandson
damn you are gangsters I am Robin Hood
like I said yeah it was half of a Ramen
yeah
I still that's so they signed I mean
that's why I don't know what's going on
I read it in Forbes thank you yeah
yeah
you Canucks man this is wow just a book
of secrets no no well listen chill
um I'm definitely gonna watch you on the
way out I was on probation
I met my wife my wife is freaking hot
you should see this girl oh this is a
bomb this is I'm telling you like wait
let me see way out of my class so I meet
my wife and I never know what's her
girlfriend we're going through this
man's text that's Brittany hottie yeah
yeah is she on the phone yeah did she
text me yeah is that your phone or his
phone oh is that my phone yeah it's your
phone there's probably nothing in here
[Laughter]
[Music]
she thinks I'm a cool guy right she
thinks like I'm this and I don't know
why she thinks I'm this but I never
really had a girlfriend I didn't really
know much about women so so things are
going very well and it's time to meet
the parents so she says this thing up
I'm going to meet her parents and they
live in Vancouver I live in Oregon but
there's just a bridge there's a little
wait a minute bridge that separates
these two states Canadian yeah yeah not
not to that Vancouver Washington oh okay
okay but there's a bridge I'm on
probation for robbing the banks so I
can't leave the state I can't go across
this bridge without written permission
and and this is set up for a Sunday
so the the federal office is closed I
can't go get this so I can't go meet her
parents so I'm explaining to her wait a
minute I'm good for the law I want to
meet but they got to come here and she's
like no they've already got it set up
and we're going over here and my family
goes around I said no no you've got to
come over you have to come over here did
you have like uh no I didn't have that
but I had everything short of that I
mean a guy that would come over to the
house and knock on the door and check
make sure you don't have any guns you
don't have any blow like stuff like this
see who was in the house and so but you
don't cuss huh I had to tell her I would
say I can't go that's why I finally had
to come class one and I'm on the
probation for the bank then so she calls
her dad and she goes uh hey you gotta
come here and the dad must have said why
is she because he's on probation
and so the dad must have said I can't
hear it I'm just standing there in front
of him and she goes what'd you do and I
said rob banks she goes robbing banks
she just repeat it all she was like so
young and innocent that she didn't
really know what I was saying and we all
went to the lunch he came anyway he came
anyway did you have any questions no no
he was fine with it no questions I swear
to goodness he actually said to her
cool
he I mean there's one [__] hmm there
he goes there's one Colony
it's the coolest crime it's robbing yeah
the people that we already feel like
we're being robbed guys yeah yeah they
really were and the people that robbed
him first yeah Rob your family yeah you
just getting a get back yeah I'm pretty
sure this is just the plot of hell or
high water but uh yeah no I like I like
those feel a lot like that yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah was that I really
know that she didn't know I didn't know
that she didn't understand what probe I
didn't know that she didn't even know
these words that she was repeating
wasn't that refreshing yeah oh it was
like you're so innocent you don't know
you haven't been with bad guys
and her dad literally paused and goes
cool and they came over and we went and
can you travel internationally I can't
now at the time I had to have a phone
and I was supposed to fight Anderson in
Brazil but it was it's called a once in
a lifetime opportunity so you can
petition the courts and I did and my
probation officer this this evil witch
named Eileen who I said no Peter yeah
she said no I had to go over her head to
a federal judge who said yes good luck
and then you went over there well they
ended up moving the fight to Las Vegas
but it was supposed to be in uh in Rio
in Rio de Janeiro yeah we were gonna go
over there I had a the probation officer
said no chill I have no [__] clue
the life of crime you didn't go with the
ski mask or anything like that you like
sound that's poor Network yeah what did
you do they call it money laundering I
don't actually know what that mean if
I'm to be fair with you I don't usually
know what money laundering means okay
but apparently I did it I did lots of it
were you doing it for a group the mafia
per se no but I got tied to that they
accused me they accused me of such
things and they accuse me of terrible
things getting the money of a bank and
then it was four Banks seven bags wow it
turned out to be 11 Banks they started
it at 1.8 million they moved to 2.6
million they went to nine something they
settled in it 15.2 million like it got
very complicated then cryptocurrency
came into it and they didn't know who
had what and then they started checking
passports and I had been in a bunch of
different country and it just got really
complicated so then we made a deal let's
just stop everybody stops whatever
you've done in exchange for whatever you
have in motion stops
when you go home jail time no no jail
time no jail ten thousand dollar fine
15.2 million for a ten thousand dollar
fine but did you have to get back
because of the Robin Hood no fifty ten
thousand dollar fine
that you paid with the money with the
very money I stole
and no one served jail time no
accomplices
on anybody how old are you sorry no I
have a guy there was a guy there were
several people that did time and one guy
had told someone in the group that that
that that I had rolled on but I I never
did never ruled anybody
at the time I was 26. and now you are
45. and you were fighting while you were
robbing these Banks and they had
cryptocurrency in 2002 2003 2008.
okay
the math is and you didn't you met this
the math is not math right now because
you're making 31. no I'm telling the
story I know I know your master I see
the problem with with whatever
well no I didn't say that this is what
happened I said this is what they were
accusing me of my mind
no you're good you're good you know what
I had a grappling match hey you want to
I think this is a grappling match
Brian makes friends with this guy in the
bar and the guy ends up hanging out with
us the entire night and he tries to get
us and this is in 2000 is this The Usual
Suspects like are you just making the
whole thing up yes it's all true yeah
and there were some palm trees yes yeah
and this guy I tries to get us hooked up
on something called Bitcoin it was a
hundred and forty six dollars and we
were like oh what can you do it Mickey
then he's like oh there's this website
you can go to it and there's certain
coffee shops that are we told we sat
there and told them basically how what a
Fooly one so what a fool you are there's
146 dollars per Bitcoin he was online he
was showing us about it yes 2011. so wow
for a Bitcoin yeah and what does he have
now is he doing all right oh that guy
probably is I don't I don't know I don't
know yeah if he held on to those that'd
be hard though you know there was a
bunch of people
like imagine those guys were in 100 yeah
you're gonna sell on the way up if you
double up it's 100 x you're like it's
pretty good those guys were Liars that
said they bought it for 40 cents and
sold it 20 000 in the height of November
of 2017. it's like you you did not he
went for 40 cents yeah what did you do
this was called money laundry
well it was just you need to get the
money to launder it yes
so well what do you how are you getting
the money
I mean I made a deal and that my deal
was I say I robbed the bank they let me
go home so you can't really asks me did
you launder the money even though in
truth I don't even know what London
laundering means I say I did I have to
say I did and they let me go they did
their end of it they let it go so you
gotta hold up I moved on with my life
got my hot ass Brittany kept all their
money
[Laughter]
[Music]
talk about the Bellator Grand Prix I
mean I really feel like somebody must
have been asleep over there but that's
the deal we made wow you asked me if I
laundered money I tell you I did
uh chill evil laughs are awesome it's
all this is all interesting the DB
Cooper story was true by the way I mean
I like throw that in on the back of
telling you a bunch of other wild and
crazy stories but like that those are
all of the interesting things of my
whole life but all of those things you
know who's DB cooper cooper is the most
famous hijacker of all time he hijacked
a plane that left Portland headed for uh
Seattle and he handcuffed himself to a
flight attendant then he opened his
briefcases before he had metal detectors
and stuff to get on airplanes and it was
what he led her to believe was a bomb
so he had him set the plane down bring
200 000 in cash and two parachutes so
they took the plane off he took the
money put one of the parachutes on and
jumped oh and they never found him never
found him never got found never you met
him yeah no he's my sister's Godfather
yeah yeah just regular guy not your
godfather too no just hers but your
parents know him but yeah
um he's dead now he's dead now but yeah
yeah it was a big deal it was a big deal
at the time then like every 10 years
somebody comes up with a new store and
Netflix just came out with one they
never have any new information
I never have any new information it's
the same information then you get a new
job information that comes along well
there was a couple of things which is
the flight attendant uh said that he was
Hispanic and she told that from day one
she and the FBI was putting out
composite drawings and they always had
it as a Caucasian and she would tell
anyone that would listen which wasn't
very many people you know there was no
internet there was no Facebook back when
this happened she had a hard time
getting an audience but anybody that
would listen she said I don't think he's
Caucasian I think he's hispanic and he
was Indian so I mean that she she was
very close on her [__] go so he had
some of the dark features you know I
think he had on like a fake mustache or
something yeah and so
um but but that was one of them and then
a big thing when they they never found
him and they never found the money they
tried to say well he would have died he
jumped into this Forest between the
Wolves and the bears in the fall itself
he would have died but what they didn't
understand is is and it relates back to
his ethnicity of being Indian is that
was all government land tens of
thousands of Acres
that backed to native land so he jumped
into his own backyard he jumped into
where he camped every so he knew exactly
where he was and the FBI speak when they
never found and they tried to sell it on
the world he might not have even made it
out and I think he I I think he had a
motorcycle that part is is me making
that up because he used to race
motorcycles
um I didn't get a motorcycle down there
drove right home that's only a
three-hour Drive did you speak to him
since the I spoke to him many times yeah
I wasn't even born until you know 27
years after this happened because my
sister's Godfather yeah and how was it
disclosed to that he was DB Cooper well
my aunt told me my aunt told me that he
was DB Cooper and my aunt asked him
they're from a really small Hometown
maybe I jumped in a little late on the
story they're from a very small Hometown
like for example there was 13 people
that graduated in their class they
played five-man football there's a
really small Hometown most of them had
never been on an airplane a lot of them
had never even seen an airplane this guy
was taking skydiving lessons like you
you had mention that to the group this
would be the hottest thing from this
town you were you're jumping out of an
airplane he and he didn't tell anyone
saying these very private lessons they
found out they found a photo and they
had to ask him and he finally copped
that he was and it was just the whole
thing was weird why wouldn't you tell us
that and then the whole DB Cooper thing
happens they call it the co-op positive
picture and it looks just like them I
mean all the dots start connecting and
my aunt said to him are you DB Cooper
they were having dinner Lee's Kitchen in
Tualatin Oregon and he said no he said
no but everything got weird the whole
table got really weird my mom and dad my
aunt and uncle he and his wife so a
couple of days later he went over to my
uncle's house and he said hey about what
she asked me and he said she's not the
only one that's put this together the
FBI's already been in my house so he
went into hiding which just he all he
did is went to Arizona but it was a very
different time back then right you could
rob a bank and move Two Towns away back
then and live the rest of your life you
put a bed you know little handkerchief
you'd never get caught so he went to
Arizona for about seven and a half years
and he he came back he ended up passing
away about four years ago was he like
pretty rich no no that was another thing
is he he had a minimum wage job he was a
night Watchman is what he did but then
he came in today they were in the
shotguns he came into these over under
shotguns were expensive and some
four-wheelers and a motorhome they just
started being these toys all of a sudden
that popped up and and my parents said
no one was like Hey where's this coming
from and um he told him that he got
Indian money he said because I'm native
every year I get money which is true he
had enough native blood that he was
getting but then that came out too and
that was 1200 a year so and so it just
didn't cover the spread and they're like
and the FBI visited him but never could
pin they went knocked on his door yeah
yeah they searched the house a little
bit they never pinned it on him no wow
where is um Jimmy hoffenberry
isn't that an interesting one what do
you think about that do you follow the
Hoffa thing
um no but I'm assuming you are a family
yeah you were involved with it no I
don't know but I watched that what was
it called the Irish pin is that what it
was called you know I thought it was
good I thought the office story was a
good one I read a book years ago where a
guy said he they aced him out and then
buried him under the Meadowlands under
the 20 yards of the old giant Stadium oh
wow yeah yeah it could be I mean they'll
tell you people aren't Above the Law oh
yes they are there's a lot of people
above the law for sure I mean but Jimmy
hoffel was one of them or whoever took
down Jimmy Hoffa yeah
um yeah there's a lot of people I mean
with you got this Giselle whatever her
name is and you know the Epstein Island
and that whole thing and they're not
looking at the list and there's people
that are above the law there you go but
that would be a great example like
whatever she knows and whoever she knows
you know
people in your town that you grew up
with or anyone in your family that was
connected to like organized crime back
in the day no no no no was your dad
pissed when he found out that you were
robbing the banks no no no he you know
he told me don't ever rob anything small
you know it's the same crime it's going
to be the same punishment that's right
whatever it's the same punishment yeah
but uh he'd passed away he didn't know
oh really oh so that was before
yeah okay okay would you have done it
when he was alive no a lot of admiration
for your pops huh yeah but I I was in
his spot it was his mom it was my
grandma's his mom I had to do it because
he wasn't here to do it yeah that the
banks would have taken from her would
they he would have done the same [__]
well he'd have done something yeah he
wasn't here so I did it
what about a movie chill what kind of
what are you thinking I don't know you
got an interesting story yeah you know
I don't know maybe someday huh maybe
something I thought they made her it's
called Catch Me If You Can yeah you got
a lot of great one it is a good movie
yeah it's a great one yes yeah they
stole a lot of your life yeah it's
pretty good he tells you how he's gonna
tell the story and then he tells you the
story yeah it still works it's true yeah